Alibaba Executive Chairman Jack Ma starts the trading day.
Ma, already worth an estimated 13 billion dollars, is getting a big payday,...
...selling more than 12 million shares and netting hundreds of millions of dollars.
Alibaba is China's leading e-commerce company...
...and operates the world's largest online market places...
...for both international and domestic trade.
The US internet technology company, Yahoo, holds nearly 24 percent of Alibaba...
...and sold 140 million shares of the IPO.
The moment Alibaba started trading, the price per share was 92 dollars and 70 cents.
It's a big start primarily for those who believed in Jack Ma from the start.
Bernard Shusman, VOA News, New York.